Now that we've learned that being clear
about value is really important for
in-app purchases,
what else can a game developer do
to improve their in-app purchases?
>> You also want to be clear about
how to use purchases in your game.
Lots of games use tutorials to
show you how to use new items.
>> When you show a player how
to use an in-app purchase,
they're much more likely
to use them in the future.
>> Also, make sure to have
variety in your purchases
to keep people interested.
And think about introducing new
items as people play the game.
>> So you could introduce a group of
items the first day someone plays
a game and then a different
group of items a week later.
>> Yep, variety is a great way to
keep players interested in your item.
And one place, though, you should
avoid variety is your price points.
Most successful games offer between
one and five price points for
all their in-app purchases.
>> This goes back to clarity, because
the value for items at each price point
has to be very clear, and
too many options can get confusing.
>> So to improve your in-app purchases,
teach players how to use them,
offer variety, and be clear about value.